I've never compromised on sleep ever you
know a lot of people know me as like I
go hard and I'm who I am but the reality
is I will sleep 10 hours a day if that's
I listen to my body very well if I can
go hard great like this week look I got
a lot to do this Saturday if I have to
sleep 14 hours to like make up for it
like I've never thought like not
sleeping is gonna make me successful
it's more while I'm awake I need to be
productive and make happen it's
very easy for me I go out like a light I
sleep all the way through and I've
always thought that it was because my
energy was always in a good place I'm
too detached for my professional career
so I don't have a lot of anxiety there
and then everything else I really care
about only is just the health and
well-being of my family and I've been
very fortunate honestly I have a level
of gratitude and even guilt on how well
I sleep you know I'm just very thankful